Star Trek's finest Hour David Lynch's
Masterpiece and a gangster movie saved
by its star more classic films were
destined for the small screen than you
might expect in 1995 Alicia Silverstone
starred as cheery upbeat fashionista
share Horowitz in Clueless a razor sharp
satire of Life at a Southern California
high school populated by a cast of
lovable oddballs clueless became a pop
culture phenomenon and catapulted just
about every member of its cast to
stardom
but this movie wasn't always ticketed
for big screen success it was originally
slated for TV the film's writer and
director Amy heckerling told
Entertainment Weekly back in 1995
originally it wasn't called Clueless
when I first pitched it as a TV show it
was called No Worries 20th Century Fox
said they wanted a show about teenagers
but not the Nerds they wanted it to be
about the cool kids according to
producer twin Kaplan though Fox wasn't
sold on their pitch in the same
interview Kaplan told entertain came in
weekly when we showed no worries to Fox
it was obvious they didn't get it they
thought the script needed more boys in
it apparently nobody quite understood
the premise of a positive Sunny teenager
in the cynical grunge obsessed early 90s
eventually however heckerling's concept
landed in the hands of a producer who
loved it and just so happened to have a
movie deal with Paramount heckerling
would eventually get her TV series too
with Stacey Dash and a sitcom spin-off
that ran for three seasons director Rob
Reiner is arguably one of Hollywood's
most underrated creatives in addition to
directing Classics like The Princess
Bride and Stand By Me He also acts with
memorable roles in everything from All
in the Family to New Girl however his
most personal project might be the 2015
film being Charlie not just because he
directed it but because it was the first
film written by his son Nick Reiner a
semi-autobiographical story of a young
man who lives in the shadows of his
famous father the movie follows Charlie
a troubled teen whose struggles land him
in rehab according to Nick however it
wasn't always destined to be a movie
originally beginning Life as a pilot
script for a half hour comedy series he
developed the concept while he himself
was staying at a rehabilitation clinic
and it eventually morphed into a script
for a movie with the help of his father
in fact the making of being Charlie
helped heal a rift between the real-life
Father and Son Duo Rob Reiner told ABC
News in 2015 over the course of making
the film our relationship definitely
changed it wasn't terrible or anything
but it got better because I then
understood a lot more of what he had
gone through and he understood a bit
more of what I had gone through arguably
David Lynch's defining film Mulholland
Drive is a dark drama about an aspiring
actress who befriends a young woman
suffering from Amnesia a masterpiece of
modern Cinema its mix of mystery crime
Noir abstract Dreamscape and genuine
Horror made it not just one of Lynch's
best but a film many consider flawless
no I Banda
it is all
fans of the film might be surprised to
learn it almost wasn't a movie at all as
Mulholland Drive was originally dreamed
up as a TV spin-off to another classic
Lynch story following the smash success
of his Prime Time Abc Thriller Twin
Peaks Lynch and co-creator Mark Frost
were preparing a second series centered
on the character Audrey home which was
to be named after a famous street in Los
Angeles where Frost lived in the book
conversations with Mark Frost the series
co-creator talked about how the movie
evolved from a TV pilot script to a
feature-length big screen success he
wrote we had considered spinning off the
Audrey character and setting her loose
in Hollywood in a modern Noir we had
very preliminary talks it drifted away
and then six years later I hear it's
going to be a pilot at ABC but when ABC
passed on the project Lynch reworked it
into a single feature film with an
entirely new cast of characters though
Frost could only speculate as to why he
said maybe because Twin Peaks had
crashed and burned after its first
season there wasn't much appetite for
spinning off a series from it in the
1980s science fiction saw a surge in
popularity the decades saw a number of
Classics about monsters or aliens coming
from outer space at the same time
dystopian sci-fi stories about
futuristic lawmen were also in Vogue so
in 1988 the gritty sci-fi crime drama
Alien Nation had the idea to marry those
two concepts putting an alien in the
role of a cop on the hunt for a killer
the film starred James Khan as Matthew
Sykes an LAPD detective who was
reluctantly partnered with alien officer
San Francisco even though alienation
turned out to be a relatively well
received movie its creator Rockne s
O'Bannon always had a TV series in mind
after failing to get a development deal
at a major Studio the project landed in
the lap of James Cameron and his partner
Gail and Hurd who hot off the production
for aliens absolutely loved the concept
with the duo of Hollywood producing
stars behind it Bannon was more than
happy to reshape his TV series into a
feature film a year after the film was
released of course Bannon would finally
get his wish when Alien Nation received
a television spin-off with its tongue
firmly planted in its rotting cheek
Zombieland is a wild satire of the
horror genre with a big name cast that
included an iconic Cameo by Bill Murray
the movie became a big box office hit
and fur time was the highest grossing
zombie movie ever made I avoided other
people like they were zombies even
before they were zombies now that they
are all zombies
I kind of miss people before it landed
in theaters however Zombieland was the
brainchild of future Deadpool writers
Rhett Rhys and Paul wernick who are
hoping to turn their idea of a humorous
zombie apocalypse into a TV series in
2009 Rhys told Gizmodo we wrote it as a
TV pilot and sold it to CBS they had a
lot of notes which we addressed and then
when they decided to not make the Pilot
We unaddressed a lot of them we went
back to what we had some were during the
rewriting process Reese and wernick
decided to turn their pilot script into
a movie screenplay instead years later
the duo got another shot at television
and filmed an episode for a spin-off as
part of Amazon's 2014 pilot program
while reviewers had kind words the
streaming service passed on turning it
into a full series
some TV to movie Evolutions come about
when a producer feels an idea is too
good to be limited to the small screen
others move their show to a future film
when a producer has connections with a
major movie studio however the 2020
gangster biopic Capone took a longer and
more complicated path it took more than
30 years two entirely different projects
and the influence of Hollywood star Tom
Hardy to get the movie made the journey
began in the 1970s with a TV pilot for a
show called Cicero the proposed series
was created by the Wild Bunch scribe
Whalen green after decades in limbo it
was finally picked up by Warner Brothers
in 2010 by which Time The Script had
evolved into a screenplay for a big
budget motion picture a year later Hardy
signed on with Harry Potter director
David Yates slated to help the project
things never fell into place however and
the project was ultimately scrapped
despite this setback party had fallen so
in love with the idea of playing Al
Capone that he revived the concept A few
years later Hardy sought the help of
beleaguered director Josh trank who turn
was looking for a comeback after years
of controversy initially titled fonzo
the final result was the streaming
original Capone the late 1990s and early
2000s were Awash with teen horror films
beginning with the wild success of
1996's scream four years later Final
Destination brought the trend into the
New Millennium sparking its own
franchise that saw a slew of sequels
over the next 11 years the first told
the story of an ill-fated Airline flight
whose would-be passengers had been
destined to die but it was almost
something else entirely believe it or
not the premise of Final Destination was
originally developed as a script for the
X-Files the proposed episode titled
flight 180 was fairly similar to what
ended up on the big screen a handful of
passengers exited a doomed flight before
takeoff after one of them has a fateful
premonition only for each of them to die
one by one in other gruesome ways
however in this earlier version the
passenger who had the premonition of the
plane's Ultimate Destruction was
scully's brother lending the story some
serious suspense as the two paranormal
investigators raced against time to save
him according to Legend however writer
Jeffrey Reddick never sent the network
his script having been advised by a
friend at newline Cinema felt the idea
was far too good to be confined to a
single episode of an existing franchise
The Landmark TV series Star Trek dazzled
audiences for three seasons in the 1960s
before low ratings forced its
cancellation but when it got hot in
reruns in the 70s talk of a Revival
surfaced and a feature film seemed like
the next logical step while audiences
were eventually handed a big budget
continuation in 1979 Star Trek the
motion picture started out as a
potential television relaunch under the
title Star Trek phase 2. heading sir
[Music]
developed as a potential Flagship series
for the launch of their own television
network Paramount brought Trek Creator
Gene Roddenberry on board and began
assembling scripts while the studio
resigned the cast to return famously
actor Leonard Nimoy declined apparently
due to tensions with the network over
the sale of merchandise featuring his
likeness nevertheless the remaining cast
was hired the sets were constructed and
the new TV series was all set to go when
a little film from George Lucas landed
in theaters after the success of Star
Wars Paramount pivoted to film they used
much of the work done for Phase 2 even
repurposing its pilot script while also
settling their conflict with Nimoy who
agreed to return his Spock remarkably
many of the original sets for Phase 2
continue to be used on spin-off shows
throughout the 1990s before being torn
down after the conclusion of Star Trek
Voyager the series that had ultimately
launched Paramount's TV network
City of the Dead isn't the kind of movie
you might expect from the title released
in 1960 the movie told the story of a
mysterious town in that turns out to be
controlled by a coven of sinister
witches some men some women whose power
came from the devil gathered beneath the
Ravens Inn to perform a black mass in
the honor of Lucifer initially developed
by screenwriter George baxt as a
television pilot City of the Dead was
intended to be a starry vehicle for
horror icon Force Karloff having found
little success with the networks at the
time producer Milton sabotsky took it
upon himself to fill out the story with
some new characters and City of the Dead
was born Stateside the film was retitled
horror hotel and it remains a cult
favorite of classic horror aficionados
today a teen Thriller film from the
mid-1990s Cruel Intentions is a dark
drama about a pair of Step siblings who
play a twisted game on a celibate school
friend the movie was a modest hit that
grew a fervent fan following so it made
perfect sense that a sequel would follow
the result was Cruel Intentions 2 a
prequel set a few years earlier at a
prestigious boarding school it followed
the exploits of a twisted teen who moves
to a new town and gets involved in some
serious drama of his own Cruel
Intentions 2 was released direct to
video in 2000 it had a noticeably
cheaper look and feel than its
predecessor and a new cast of Mostly
unknowns viewers of the first film who
saw the sequel may have suspected what
we all know now the sequel was
originally filmed as a TV pilot as it
turns out following the success of the
first movie a spin-off prequel titled
Manchester prep was developed and at
least two episodes were filmed
unimpressed with the results and
concerned its envelope pushing story
might not play on network TV the studio
scuttled the project in an attempt to
recoup their investment they chopped up
the episodes and repackaged them as a
directive video feature
foreign
[Music]